yellow welcome to new video this will be
one of those entertainment only hit
video some it's a bullet Tony here
coming up on chess cube one minute anger
always played at 50 minutes past six in
the evening here German time so I rarely
get to play this but managed today so
let's see what happens I need to get rid
of this here ok let's see a French
defence ok yeah you get this exchange
line very often I hope I'm can manage to
play halfway quickly here at some these
first game is always difficult for me
I'm tend to play far too slowly alright
so I played a long castle CM at age 3
was very nice of him of course allowing
me to to open lines here ok cannot oops
get to h2 immediately but this looks
very dangerous now for white ok let's
take the piece take this um yeah just
him Queen h1 checkmate this was posted
console oh ok
this is checkmate right not yet hmm okay
c3 made now don't manage a medium
valuable just my own blindness i guess
but okay he resigned very nice okay so
it is to win first games always oops
what I accidentally resigned yet I hit
the wrong button okay so making it a bit
tough on myself what here's resins and
here's the doubling and somehow I even
that confirmed it alright so so well
what can you do so somebody it opening
here okay it looks a bit like French the
French sideline him so should i cancel i
don't know she'll be too bad ok so don't
mind us that much i want to get dumb a
bishop on c6 okay i also need to realize
that this is actually one minute and not
to usually there are those two minutes
tournament on on mental chess cube and
one minute is really something else okay
so go inside is closed so i hope to get
something going on the kingside soon
okay not quite sure benefits here from
the g file but i hope i can i can do
something yeah we can take on age six
now but I have some supply myself take
here can also take the Queen something
maybe this one
trying to pre move this irritated him oh
why did we attorney okay so hope I get
it a normal stride here soon otherwise
this is gone before it's really started
okay the London system so pretty quite
looking opening okay night xf7 I could
have played this is also very nice okay
so why should I go now now 94 we can can
play maybe not a Quincy form yeah and
far too slow here it's really a really
pays off to play some games before but I
simply started this tournament okay take
26 simply started this and didn't do any
practice games before I guess it really
helps ok now I'm long just peace up but
bit down on time
I have pretty good control here in this
position so should should be okay
tireless sighs the only issue as usual
should be 52 is six would be nice would
be checked laid a yep not immediately
but close to it rookie seven made now
threatened here we go okay so some guy
is caught for the form yeah this
accidental resign didn't really help
this is really first for me it happened
to me and I see a couple of years ago
why accidentally really resigned yeah
I'm not quitting and you get this this
match the message like you really want
to resign and actually yeah I hit the
button and no idea no idea why so this
is really curious it happens obviously
ok no no idea about this opening I've
got this this the Kings gambit declined
which I don't know anything about so
this might be total crap okay so i can i
can give this chicken is bishop is also
hanging so it's nothing and now maybe
here to get development going night no
threat no okay so talk back and not d5
okay i can go here winning the night i
think i can take with check okay so i
don't win the night with but it's
looking nicely check here now I've got a
nice rook there
she cannot take our queen e5 should be
quite good attacking c3 Queen a to now
threatened I could have taken the Rocio
okay so yeah what happened five five out
of five somewhere squad so I need some
quick win may be here Poland is very low
rated which doesn't necessarily mean
anything but maybe some Evans gambit or
something can do the trick okay first of
all it's okay g6 so let's try to open up
the position quickly here if it takes my
place III
okay yeah it looks fairly closed maybe I
can get something quickly on f7 if you
please Knight f6 for instance want to
provoke f6 then I just drop back in time
you cannot castle
now maybe h4 h5 I Bishop g4 I can play
yeah I need to watch the time I'm doing
comment area like this is a five-minute
game and it's just bullet some not
really in bullet mode hey this is just
bogus for a plate in bulk Emmett I need
to play quickly maybe maybe this is
actually not so bad Queen age five could
could help and he's very slow oops come
on take him so stare quit made coming up
somehow don't see it i mean the bishop
is just as lost but ok some okay let's
take it okay we'll step the time so i'm
close here 656 someone has okay some be
three line maybe i can get something
here on this weekend diagonal spinning
action here Queenie five also coming
this might be quite good l can just take
him just wanted peace until he's also
got the king in the middle so the center
so i should get some tech going here
t for mt4 taking only three should be
should be quite dangerous to say the
least when I can take anywhere yeah just
an extra piece it's no made but still a
pretty easy win
yeah let's grab grab some more pawns ok
some catching up a bit but as long as
those guys win every game that's
difficult you shouldn't be it's like 40
degrees cooler after that video ok this
quick win actually got me to place one
for for a minute yeah some really
strange opening but you know he falls
was a bit bit but strange I think ok
I've got c4 yeah what what do I do now
not quite sure how to set up my pieces
here
okay let's grab this one and now tries
for c5c for this looks like a good plan
even with the King here I could have
plates you four already
right so maybe I get something going
here Roxy for OPM looks very dangerous
night here come on isn't this something
this is made right Queen a to mate I'll
just prevent this okay okay fine so this
is good slowly oh my so I'm leading and
winning quickly it's it's cool I am okay
so some weird Scandinavian line here I
want to get get rid of the bishop to
weaken the slide squares oh this one's
huge month material fee retakes 97 so
I'm just a piece up for nothing and what
a piece and that's ahead senator once
the bishop will be three so let's get a
piece to see for here and of course I
want to play a form opening the position
yeah very nice the extra piece and even
got the better position
now you just exchanges everything down
to a piece down end game maybe hoping
for for some time time issue but its
sides very winning right one one point
ahead here so it's very very close in
those bullet tournaments I mean to super
quick wins can can just turn the tables
completely under now the game doesn't
get started this also doesn't really
help I mean what's this I need a new
game come on well this is just just bad
having those technical issues I mean if
you're lucky you can win a game in those
30 seconds that are past now it's just
not not much you can do yeah the
meantime someone overtook me here
yeah son that wasn't their own I saw
that over ok so the tournament ok I've
got a new game going that's a better
opponent now it's tire rated so oh this
is nice Bishop take that three is
actually good move it's not not the
trick move but it helped ok so the
lattice 1 to 1 1 2 3 4 Plain quite often
here so Kings in in time
yeah oops this wasn't intended I guess
looks like a nice song nice it check
here look g1 now threatened syrup g1
yeah winning the Queen now this looks
good fine so I'm actually 40 points
ahead or something the other guys must
have lost games came ok some Vienna game
coming here I gained this King's gambit
stuff getting into this actually
accidentally is so no fun ok I try to
get some counter play him in the center
with c 6 and so on ok so maybe I can can
get something on the queenside on this
could help c 50 c 5 video came oh this
is ok now i think this piece is sound
quite a problem now i just need to get
to see Five to attack a three I couldn't
be fine i'll give out it's not a bad
position I hope
ph coming no idea what this kind of
position is that's just it all right we
don't want to draw okay also I've got a
repetition all right in the meantime
someone really caught up here eight
points behind which means just eight
points means just a game if you wince
again before I do he get lots of points
so maybe a quick Sicilian win if
possible could help oh this wasn't
intended
alright so it's nothing special here but
maybe I can get something on the king oh
this is ok now we five it's a nice juicy
porn threaten to take now and take h7
not quite sure what is doing against
this ok maybe this helps pinning pinning
the bishop and look rook e8 now
threatening media luc GA drew a Juliet
is almost made or it is made maybe in ok
first is check I can also just down just
grab the regret piece here which I will
do pieces of peace only the background
cam ok any to pay attention here
exchange first and it's an extra piece
ok resins nice so still in the lead
seven minutes to go on
speculating him okay didn't help all
right you grab d5 so this should be nice
for me but maybe oops not a quick win
but maybe it is a quick one he just
gives me a piece it's always helpful
short castle come on short castle would
be really nice now yeah Quinn g3 the
abbey sugar-frosted save the peace
maybe there was something better
possible but that's not bad just whoops
oh I didn't see this one at all should
have really okay so maybe she pissy 595
should lead to some some attack here and
maybe if 50 well this this was will most
likely decided on time anyway because
he's so slow to get something going on
the eval it takes but this was so this
isn't really good time but it irritates
him another thing to to gain some time
okay time one yeah someone's really
keeping up here just eight points so a
very good wind would help yeah thanks
this was nice but still he sir would
then one one win of my score okay maybe
the Kings Kings gambit helps to win some
some some again quickly all right so i
can open up the position here this looks
nice really got a nice development going
and 93 maybe helps a winning material at
some point there should be a very strong
attack so in this check made somehow
okay at least this one speck needs
change and that's to live in the tech
somehow Queen to e3 and it sets out them
I don't see how though okay let's scrap
piece it's still a huge attack okay at
least a win and I'm I'm still ahead
three and a half minutes to go maybe for
would have been better with okay
sometimes I just automatically player to
form some my usual stuff if I was just
better suited to win win really quickly
in those tournaments I feel so maybe not
a great idea but let's see what happens
trying to get towards the king even if
this is not oops not the best possible
what is he doing here very generous okay
summer look up but of course the game
continues if I've would be nice winning
the special also okay maybe I could have
exchanged Queens but still hoping to to
meet him somehow
okay some Queens right after all what
whatever it's an extra rook
and like doesn't have any play really
for this look even time why some fine
okay grab this one as well okay 140
something to go and I'm still ahead so
for win this this might be enough so
let's observe haha i play d6 bullet yeah
you need to be guys will you try try
stuff against you Bishop g5 unbelievable
you can work if you don't pay attention
Knight f3 you can be huge move okay here
tender to this let's take here here here
we go right here yeah the shirt this is
me tnx move and maybe that's it maybe
I've got it now 20 seconds you can let
the clock run down and 33 left so
someone overtook me but I've got this
game in the bag so it's 20 seconds to go
unless he wins another game in 20
seconds I should have done it that's
it's just it's just working out nicely
he's got seven seven seconds seven
seconds or something left yet ok this
guy wins another one he's his he's the
winner no I just got my win in and now 5
for liquid countdown ok this is this
game doesn't do anything
yeah I've done it their first place yeah
fun tournament I think I lost I've made
one draw and lost this this great game
had accidentally recited okay i hope you
enjoyed the tournament I did yeah okay
thanks for watching and see you soon
with new videos